hey guys what's up this is going to be
video all about Hodor a lot of you have
asked for video explaining what's going
on with his character the last time we
saw him
it was very ambiguous so just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened through season six so far
there's a lot of evidence to suggest
that we're going to see him again and
there's a number of different ways the
show could accomplish that based on
brands abilities in a couple key scenes
that I'll explain so there is a new
round of the game of Thrones giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's for one of the enhanced
editions of the books there are two big
ways the show could bring him back one
is a white which would be just
absolutely horrifying and two in another
brand flashback so let's start with the
really cool one first
Hodor as a white so a lot of you have
asked what happened to Hodor after he
held the door for bran and Meera so that
they could escape so there are a couple
key scenes that sort of explain what's
going on in why he might come back as a
white and a white Walker is slightly
different he might come back as a white
Walker pending benjin's explanation
which is another key scene what he
explained how he was slowly being turned
into another white Walker himself so at
the end of episode five we get to
explain her for his name that's the big
reveal hold the door
Bryan had simultaneously skin shifted
into Hodor and was controlling him to
hold the door while he was also in the
past watching what was happening at
Winterfell he doesn't fully understand
how his magic works yet so it creates
this crazy feedback loop that
short-circuits some of the language
centers of Hodor spray the way they
presented Hodor in the early seasons is
that he's simple-minded but you learned
that he does understand everyone he just
the speech centers of his brain that
have been affected so in this moment he
sort of gets subconsciously stuck on
this future moment he probably never
fully understood what was going on till
he was in that moment himself
[Music]
total Kajol Hojo
but there's a big revelation that we've
gotten in the last season is that the
others or the White Walkers every want
to call them they're only called White
Walkers on the TV show in the books
they're called others they have an
intelligence of their own they're not
just mindless drones the knight King is
probably the most powerful person on the
planet next to brand right now so he
wants to swell his ranks but typically
dead people are raised as White's not as
White Walkers so they're really fuzzy on
the rules for how you create a white
Walker but we do know that only the
knight king can create new White Walkers
the White Walkers themselves can raise
White's one at a time but the knight
King can raise them all at once so very
different power levels but a lot of it
just depends on what their plan is for
any given person so the reason that the
knight King probably wanted to turn
Benjen into another white Walker is
because of his skills into his knowledge
so once you become a white Walker you're
basically a thrall of the knight King
you do have like your own intelligence
in your own agency but you're bound to
him so whoever you were before just
completely disappears had benjin been
fully turned he would have killed bran
and Meera on the spot
perfect
the last letter John wrote me said had
been lost beyond the wall
that arranging party deep into the north
to find White Walkers they found us like
Walker stabbed me in the gut the sword
of ice that we better die richer
children film stop the walkers magic
from taken hold how the same way they
made the walkers in the first place you
saw it yourself
dragonglass a shot of dragonglass punch
into your heart but what about Hodor
it would be a crazy WTF to see him come
back in a crowd shot as a white Walker
or as a white but which one would just
depend on whether or not you believe
that he died in that moment whether he
was ripped to shreds or not because they
can animate whites that are basically
just skeleton this Ray Harryhausen
looking white here is almost full
skeleton from the end of season 4
so odds are pretty good Hodor is not
dead in the truest sense of the word and
when people asked george RR martin about
it because Dan and Dave got this Hodor
twist from him he said have you seen a
body you know maybe hodor's not that
he's very ambiguous about stuff like
that so you're just left to wonder so if
there is a chance that he's alive he's
probably still alive but not in the way
that you would expect because while
benjin had the children of the forest to
save him from being turned into a white
Walker
Hodor does not have that he has an army
of whites that are trying to get through
that door they weren't really clear
about it either but the actor who plays
bran was mostly responding to the Hodor
twist like nice one brand you said it's
all in motion killed a three-eyed raven
and got Hodor killed too but the even
bigger implication is that the children
of the forest have died off now that
those were like the final surviving
members of their race
[Music]
now part of the reason I think they're
being so ambiguous is because they want
brand to be on his own he says to benjin
you know I don't understand my powers I
didn't get the full explainer from the
three-eyed Raven before he uploaded all
of his knowledge into my mind which is
basically what was happening he was
unlocking some of brands abilities but
at the same time uploading all this
knowledge that he had accumulated so if
you want to believe that Hodor is coming
back as a white or even a white Walker
although I think it'd be more likely
that he would be a white he would have
to be some moment that they would save
for the brand character just because
it'd be more meaningful that way him
seeing twisted Hodor and being
confronted with his failure so there are
a number of reasons why you could argue
that they will not bring Hodor back as a
white so typically the big twist on the
TV show have some deeper meaning to the
story like the big twist about White
Walkers being the creation of the
children of the forest when they were
fighting the first men in their big war
for Westeros their whole line of logic
is that they were losing and then they
needed a weapon of mass destruction to
stop the first men from completely
destroying their race but in doing so
they lost control of their own creation
and now they threaten everyone so it's a
big WTF twist but it makes sense from a
narrative perspective you create the
thing that will eventually destroy you
so whoever you're fighting the war
against isn't your greatest enemy you
are your own greatest enemy or your
failings or your hubris or your
weaknesses it's the same thing with
Cersei Circe's greatest enemy isn't the
faith of the seven or wasn't the faces
of seven because she took care of them
at the end of the season it's really
herself she will do something that will
lead to her own downfall in the way that
the children of the forest did so I'm
less likely to back some big WTF twist
theory unless it's in service of
wrapping up a really awesome plotline
like the idea that Arya would cross
Circe's name off her list while at the
same time fulfilling the prophecy of the
valonqar by wearing Jaime's face you
know that's like a crazy WTF twist
theory but it helps sew up a lot of the
logic in the books whether or not the TV
show decide
to go that route so let me know do you
think that Hodor is going to come back
as a white in a future season whether
it's in the books or on the TV show it's
totally possible if you just go based on
the logic of what they presented so far
he would have to be a white but it just
depends on what types of scenes they
want to do with White Walkers in season
seven but in related news I know a lot
of you are asking about a video ranking
the characters based on their magic
abilities so I'll be doing a video for
that this week but feel free to leave
other suggestions for Game of Thrones
videos you guys want me to do on the
channel well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my Arya
Stark Balon Carr video and you can click
here to learn how Marvel is getting
ready for a really big reboot in the
next couple of years thank you so much
for watching everybody
what's that five I'll see you guys
tonight